bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce journal du
mardi 24 mars voilà ce que l'on peut
retenir dans l'actualité de ce jour 150
parents d'élèves ce samedi au lycée jean
vilar de plaisir pour une explication
autour des dangers d'internet pour leurs
enfants une initiative de l'association
ou en france elle s'appelle sonia porot
à 35 ans elle est la nouvelle secrétaire
général de la cgt des yvelines invités
de cette édition elle nous parlera de
ses ambitions des prochains combats à
mener le lui demanderont aussi son
regard sur la parité en politique ils
étaient près de cent mille mille huit
cents coureurs à avoir participé à l'eco
trail une course de 80 km partie de
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines pour rejoindre partie paris une
compétition qui n'est le sport et
environnement
mais d'abord on démarre ce journal avec
une image celle de bertrand chapelle il
est professeur au lycée hôtelier de huy
en cours et vient de remporter à
chamalières puy-de-dôme à la finale
nationale de la coupe georges baptiste
2015 une coupe qui récompense le
meilleur maître d'hôtel de l'année bravo
donc à lui le lycée hôtelier encore
distingué la semaine dernière c'était
l'un de ses étudiants baptiste vial qui
était devenu champion de france des
desserts les 27 28 et 29 mars prochain
trois jours pour favoriser la recherche
ou contre le sida le sidaction 2015 va
tenter de collecter un maximum de fonds
à travers différentes actions dans toute
la france et à l'université de
versailles saint quentin l'association
achète prévention prend un peu d'avancé
les dépistages rapides sont proposées
toute la journée une minute pour savoir
et éviter la banalisation d'une
infection qui touche encore 6 à 7000
nouvelles personnes chaque année en
france on écoute son président jérôme
andré au micro de yolaine thorez l'idée
c'est de réduire les risques que les
gens comprennent où est-ce qu'ils
prennent donc des risques sexuels et
puis qu'ils puissent aussi avoir une
réponse quand
alors statut sérologique sur le sida les
étudiants c'est un coeur de cible c'est
une population donc à risque on le sait
tous il y avait pas mal de soirées il ya
pas mal aussi de conduites à risques je
pense à l'alcool mais notamment entre
autres mais pas seulement et c'est vrai
que pour le coup on a une vraie
nécessité à venir les dépister
régulièrement en l'occurrence sur saint
quentin on aimerait bien que ce soit un
peu plus que simplement une fois par an
nous on estime qu'il faudrait que ce
soit deux à trois fois par an pour
effectivement avoir une vraie action de
prévention
éducation pour continuer internet
évidemment cet outil révolutionnaire
utiliser de plus en plus dans le
quotidien comporte également des dangers
pour sensibiliser les parents à ces
risques que l'association e-enfance
organisé samedi dernier au lycée jean
vilar de plaisir une conférence à
destination des familles 150 parents
d'élèves de trois collèges de la ville
se sont rendus sur place williams elle
pas très gai unis smid
nous l'utilisons tous les jours mais ces
dangers sont souvent méconnus internet
et ses risques voilà le sujet de la
conférence tenue samedi dernier par
l'association e-enfance au lycée jean
vilar de plaisir où plus d'une centaine
de parents sont venus s'informer les
at-il sont maintenant parfois un peu
dépassé par toutes ces nouveautés
technologiques par tous ses accès
internet donc c'est pour ça que nous
avons souhaité faire cette action auprès
des parents au programme apprendre à
gérer son image sur les réseaux sociaux
mais aussi à reconnaître les sites non
recommandables des exemples très simple
très concret moi quand je vois certaines
photos par exemple de certains élèves
sur facebook ce qu'ils oublient c'est
que une fois qu'ils ont mis une photo
sur facebook ne leur appartient plus et
donc elle peut devient un peu n'importe
quoi on peut la retrouver un peu partout
au coeur du débat les jeux vidéo en
ligne dieu des changes mais également
nouveau terrain de chasse des prédateurs
sexuels
les parents quant à eux découvrent un
aspect d'internet totalement nouveau
j'ai la chance d'avoir deux filles qui a
priori sont pas ne sont pas des fans de
jeux vidéo déjà donc j'écarte ce sujet
là parce que ce que je viens d'entendre
effectivement fait un peu peur mais moi
c'est plutôt vis-à-vis des réseaux
sociaux et tout ce qui vous fait peur du
vis-à-vis des réseaux sociaux
de ce qu'elles peuvent mettre en ligne
sans se rend compte de la portée de ce
que ça peut avoir justement
l'intervenant est très intéressant il
explique plein de choses auxquelles on
ne pense même pas et et je vais me
dépêcher les retourner
c'est la première intervention de
l'association sur la ville de plaisir
pour toute information supplémentaire un
site internet et un numéro vert reste
disponible
notre invité de ce soir sonia porot
bonsoir vous êtes la nouvelle secrétaire
général cgt des yvelines à 35 ans vous
avez été élu par vos pairs le 12 mars
dernier pour un mandat de trois ans vous
êtes la seule femme élue secrétaire
générale en ile de france est-ce que ça
a un sens évidemment pour vous oui c'est
un sens pour moi et pour pour toute la
cgt qui cherche à être représentatifs de
l'ensemble des salariés donc aussi les
femmes qui sont la moitié de la
population qui ont parfois des
difficultés
supplémentaires du fait des
discriminations ou des préjugés sexistes
la double journée de travail les
familles monoparentales qui sont
majoritairement féminine donc c'est
effectivement à signaler ce pardon
secrétaire général d'une confédération
comme la cgt à la tête des yvelines ça
veut dire que forcément si on est une
femme on va on va appliquer des papas
des méthodes mais en tout cas on
s'intéresse à des thématiques très
particulière on aura vécu hier dans
toute la cgt travail à cette question de
la mixité
mais je pense que le fait qu'ils aient
une femme à la tête ça peut aussi voilà
donnez plus + l'envi rassurer d'autres
femmes de pour s'engager dans l'action
syndicale la féminisation des instances
syndicales c'est une vraie réalité alors
ici dans les yvelines je crois que le
comité exécutif comprend 35 femmes
aujourd'hui 25% 35% par nombre de femmes
et vous m'aviez dit à peu près dix ans
il n'y avait que 20 % donc ça se
féminise d'opposants louis bien sûr et
c'est c'est une volonté et des actions
concrètes pour y arriver et tout la cgt
est engagé est engagée là dessus avec à
la direction confédérale à la parité
même est le nouveau secrétaire philippe
martinez qui avait été le 3 février
dernier la suite de la démission de
thierry le paon donc le bureau
confédéral compte dix membres il ya cinq
femmes et cinq hommes pourquoi tu vas
parler de la parité qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la parité justement puisqu'on
en parle beaucoup en ce moment sur la
représentativité politique avec la
possibilité que des binômes hommes
femmes donc se présente pour ces
élections départementales c'est une
bonne chose il faut pousser la venue des
femmes dans les oui je pense que dans la
situation actuelle il ya besoin
effectivement d'un effort particulier
pour que les femmes puissent puisse
s'engager et à égalité avec avec les
hommes dans l'idéal il faudrait que ça
devienne banal qu'une femme soit à des
positions de responsabilité dans
l'entreprise dans les organisations
syndicales comme dans le monde politique
donc j'ai dit vous êtes la nouvelle
secrétaire générale de la cgt vous avez
35 ans votre premier engagement remonte
en 2008 c'est là où vous avez adhéré à
la cgt vous étiez téléconseillère sur un
site de montigny qui est fermé depuis
alors pourquoi un engagement syndical en
2008 et pourquoi la cgt
l'engagement syndical il est venu assez
de manière assez évidente vu les vues
les conditions de de travail et les
niveaux de salaires la cgt sait c'est le
syndicat qui pour moi était le plus
dynamique c'est le syndicat où il ya le
plus le plus adhérent le plus de
diversité il ya toute une histoire de la
cgt qui qui m'a plu aussi et j'ai trouvé
une cgt plus plus ouverte plus plus
dynamiques même que ce que j'attendais
avant d'y être aujourd'hui vous êtes à
la tête donc de cette confédération dans
les îles où vous allez souhaité apporter
quoi du coup alors à la fois un peu
votre jeunesse peut-être un regard
nouveau sur le monde du travail vous
arrivez du secteur privé oui voilà basse
et c'est aussi comment comment être à
l'écouté répondre aux attentes de
l'ensemble des salariés comment on peut
répondre aux attentes des ingénieurs
cadres et techniciens qui sont
majoritaires dans le département comment
on peut s'adresser de manière pertinente
aux jeunes les apprentis les jeunes
diplômés
donc ces questions là bas c'est vrai que
quand on voit quelqu'un de jeune ça
facilite c'est ce qu'on s'est rendu
compte la cgt compte plus de 8000
adhérents dans les yvelines c'est le
premier syndicat du département votre
objectif pour ce mandat de trois ans
évidemment de recruter plus d'adhérents
peut-être d'adhérents oui parce que ça
va jouer le fait que vous soyez une
femme les adhérents on verra après cc
c'est un engagement de l'ensemble de nos
syndicats de nos unions locales de nous
de nos syndiqués aussi de nos élus dans
l'est dans les entreprises mais oui les
adhérents c'est le coeur de la cgt avec
la volonté qu'ils puissent participer
s'exprimer donc ça c'est un travail au
quotidien pour qu'ils aient ces espaces
là d'expression pour porter leurs
revendications et d'indication le
prochain combat entre guillemets vous
allez mener c'est le 9 avril la
manifestation le 9 avril voit la
manifestation nationale à paris 1 contre
contre toutes les politiques d'austérité
qui qui remettent en cause aussi le
droit du travail qui remettent en cause
les services publics auquel on est
attaché on en a beaucoup parlé dans
notre congrès départemental comment
avoir des services publics d emploi d
industrie qui sont à la pour répondre
aux besoins de la population et qui
permettent aux salariés d'en vivre et
d'en vivre bien merci sonia porot d'être
sur le mot merci avait des fils du
journal vous êtes la nouvelle secrétaire
générale de la cgt d évident merci à
vous pouvez terminer ce journal en
parlant de sport ce samedi se tenait la
huitième édition de l'eco trail une
course de 80 km qui s'est élancé depuis
l'île des loisirs de 50 ans olivier avec
pour objectif le premier étage de la
tour eiffel rien que cela plus de 1700
coureurs y ont participé à une course
exigeante qui demande beaucoup eu de
préparation mélanie poquet patrick jacq
de x men à
11h30 derniers préparatifs les 1734
participants à l'eco trail sont au point
de rendez vous pour l'épreuve-reine 80
kilomètres à travers les yvelines les
hauts-de-seine et paris venus de toute
la france ils se sont préparés avec un
programme exigeant pour ce type de
course et un entraînement quotidien
d'environ 20 km du lundi au jeudi et 30
km le vendredi samedi dimanche donc ça
me fait des semaines de 170 km quoi
c'est la première fois que je fais cette
gauche parce que je l'avais pas la mode
palmarès
donc j'essaie de voilà d'arriver à bon
état avoir une heure du matin à la tour
eiffel l'eco trail c'est aussi une
sensibilisation à l'écologie est une
bonne ambiance les organisateurs se sont
engagés à reverser 7500 euros à l'office
national des forêts ce jour là il a
fallu composer que le froid mais aussi
le pic de pollution pour cette huitième
édition le nuage qui recouvrait la
capitale et l'île de france depuis
plusieurs jours était de la partie
j'essaie d'appeler les courses pour
savoir un peu c'était martin ou pas mais
là ils annoncent un taux élevé de
pollution donc j'espère que on va rien
attraper que les explorations
fonctionnelles respiratoires de le faire
chez le primeur log lundi tout se
passera bien quoi nous en fait on est
régime allez les directives des
préfectures donc si la course a lieu
c'est que les préfectures ont décrété
que remettait personne en danger mon à
des gens qui sont relativement aguerri
sur ses longues distances
ils font ça de manière raisonnée nous on
leur fait signer une charte éthique qui
dit faites attention à vous faites
attention aux autres faites attention la
nature dans que je pense qu'ils sont
sensibilisés à sa midi le départ est
donné direction paris et le premier
étage de la tour eiffel
emmanuel gault déjà vainqueur l'an
dernier réalisera les 80 km d'épreuves
en 5h35
les autres participants avaient jusqu'à
une heure du matin pour rallier la ligne
d'arrivée
1559 coureurs l'ont franchie
selon elle est maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous de
l'information locale demain toujours en
direct à 18h bonne soirée